so basically I don't know I guess this a
question for like everyone but like
after like let's say when I stop doing
of I'm still going to obviously have
that um still surrounded around me
because you know social media and Google
and Reddit interet never yeah they will
never forget anything that I do and I
love it you know I won't ever put
something out there that you know I'm
going to want to take down later um but
like how do I don't know like how do I
move gone from that through like
relationships cuz now it's so hard for
me to find someone who wants to commit
and after that I'm G to have it's going
to be have to something I'm going to
speak about where I'm like yeah I used
to do that and I don't but like you
there's also you know trolls and I'm
probably going to be streaming for a
very long time it's just something that
like fulfills my own personal needs
leave that for the ladies if they want
to chime in on that
first
I don't know I guess like for me I would
say that would have been something you
should have thought about before you did
it right like before you kind of got
into that world because it's that's like
you know what I mean like I do all the
modeling but I make sure it's modeling
that is not something I wouldn't want my
grandma to look at right so it's just
that kind of thing and it's not an image
that I just believe sex between your
partner and stuff right like any sexual
act whether it's Solo or not should be
something you share with just your
partner right and then so like when he
sees you like you're giving something
that he wants to everybody else so you
keep it's not just for him well that's
that's the thing I don't really see it
as like I give that to everybody else
because it's it's virtual no one's ever
met up with me I don't meet up with
subscribers you know like I you know I
do a very limited set of stuff of like
full send content so some I don't know
how I'm gonna be able well I guess
they're just seeing your body in a way
that you know what I mean it's like
that's for should be for his eyes only
right because a lot of men will kind of
see it that way right like you just lose
I don't know I guess in someone you can
because I've talked to man about this
because I knew a girl that did only fans
and we did like a shoot and stuff a
different thing and we were at a party
and someone just kind of brought up the
fact that she did only fans and there
was a guy there all night that had no
idea that she did and as soon as it
happened you saw his face kind of change
and then we just asked him and he said
like as soon as he heard that like he
lost the respect for her right it was
just like an instant kind of a loss of
respect so that might be something you
face which is hard okay yeah I don't
mean that in any disrespectful no no no
you're good yeah
I think it depends what kind of men
you're looking for like if you for
example if you want High Caliber men
it's very hard because the thing is they
would have friends and their friends
would have seen you naked and it's just
not a good look and it's embarrassing
like you know what I mean like they
would just not take you seriously for
sure so like there there are caliber of
men who will take it but you would have
to take what comes with it like they'll
be feminine they would be you know not
as masculine that will probably not
very successful if you're happy with
that you will be able to find men like
that so you just have to manage your
expectation of what kind of men you're
looking for and what you want to attract
and what you can get be realistic with
that okay I always thought about you
know like being a single mom if if
nothing works out but then we had that
talk about how single mothers maybe
don't do as good as a job don't do that
um I mean I also think that has
something to do with like therapy like
our like at least my parents grew up in
a generation where like therapy was
looked down upon I feel like that maybe
that's just something I mean look as far
as therapy goes you're better off rather
than spending hundreds of dollars going
to a therapist like just watching my
YouTube channel for free or going out
and doing seven grams of mushrooms and
going on a full-on Heroes trip and
you'll fix yourself up real fast with
stuff like that um M you got any advice
for on the
question I was hoping come to me it's
GNA be difficult I mean we don't want to
sugarcoat it's gonna it's going to come
up there's going to be guys that are
going to have issues with it I think
Andrew brings up a good point where you
know guys are very particular and they
want their woman to be their woman and
only for them and I think you know
there's a reason why you don't see and I
don't mean to draw such a direct
correlation and parallel here but
there's a reason why like porn star
relationships almost never work out
unless they date other porn stars or
they marry other porn stars because
they're just in that life and so you
know the first time somebody maybe
you're dating a guy he gets a text
message from a buddy's like hey here's
your you know wife on only fans doing
XYZ showings XYZ ABC and so you know
you've got a you got a good opportunity
now to try to prepare yourself for those
conversations and you have full control
over anything else that you continue to
do content wise um and
so I think you just got to prepare
yourself for some potentially very
difficult conversations and for some
guys to have a visceral reaction towards
it I think men are hardwired to look
down upon and be sort
of turned off
by any promiscuity or things that could
be construed as promiscuity even though
you know there's some Nuance essentially
to your content it's you're not doing it
with other people and things like that
but um to Danica's Point you're sort of
sharing something with the world that a
man expects his woman to only share with
him so um I don't have a perfect answer
for you I think just prepare yourself
for there's going to be guys that that's
just going to be a deal breaker for you
um I think realistic practical advice is
when you're done try to bury it as much
as you possibly can and if you could lie
essentially like if you can because I
just think there's just such a I just
don't think being upfront and honest
about it is going to do you any favors I
think that in a perfect world we can all
do things that we everything that we
want and we don't ever have any
repercussions or we don't ever have to
answer for them but we unfortunately
don't live in that world so if you're
strictly looking to
self-preservation and it's it's there's
certainly no easy answer yeah I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the fulll length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
Down Below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out